today is very rarely modular take this
motorcycle jacket as an example it's a
pretty standard jacket with its buttons
and it zippers and it's trim but in
order for us to efficiently recycle a
jacket like this we need to be able to
easily remove these items and quickly
get down to just the fabric once we have
just the fabric we're able to break it
down by shredding it and getting back to
the thread level make new thread then
gets made into new fabric and ultimately
new clothing whether it be a new jacket
or new t-shirts for example but the
complexity lies with all of these extra
items the buttons and the zippers
the trim because in reality these items
are actually quite difficult to remove
so in many cases it requires more time
or more money to disassemble a jacket
like this in some cases it's just more
cost-effective to throw it away rather
than recycle it but I think this can
change if we design clothes in a modular
way to be easily disassembled at the end
of the lives we could redesign this
jacket to have a hidden wireframe kind
of like the skeleton of a fish that
holds all important items together this
invisible fish bone structure can have
all of these extra items the zippers and
the buttons and the trim sewn into it
and then attach to the fabric so at the
end of the jackets life all you have to
do is remove this fish bone and the
fabric comes with it a lot quicker and a
lot easier than before now recycling
clothing is definitely one piece of the
puzzle but if we want to take fixing the
environmental impact of the fashion
industry has more seriously then we need
to take this to the next step and start
to design clothes to also be compostable
at the end of their lives for most of
the types of clothes that we have in our
closet the average lifespan of these
items is about three years now I'm sure
there's many of us that have gems in our
drawers that are much older than that
which is great because being able to
extend the life of a garment by even
only nine months reduces the waste and
water impact of that garment has by
twenty to thirty percent but fashion is
fashion which means that styles are
always gonna change and you're probably
going to be wearing something different
then you wear today eight seasons from
now no matter how environmentally
friendly you want to be but lucky for us
there's some items that never go out of
style I'm talking about your basics
stuff like your socks your underwear
even your pajamas we're all guilty of
wearing these items right down to the
bone and in many cases throwing them in
the garbage because it's really
difficult to donate your old ratty socks
that have holes in them to your local
thrift store but what if we were able to
compost these items rather than throw
them in the trash bin the environmental
savings could be huge and all we would
have to do is start to shift more of our
resources to start to produce more of
these items using more natural fibers
like 100% organic cotton
now recycling and composting are two
critical priorities but one other thing
that we have to rethink is the way that
we die our clothes currently 10 to 20%
of the harsh chemical dye that we use
end up in water bodies that neighbor
production hubs in developing nations
the tricky thing is is that
harsh chemicals are really effective at
keeping a garment a specific color for a
long period of time if these harsh
chemicals that keep that bright red
dress bright red for so many years
but what if we were able to use
something different what if we were able
to use something that we all have in our
kitchen cabinets at home to dye our
clothes what if we were able to use
spices and herbs to dye our clothes
there's countless food options that
would allow for us sustained material
but these stains change color over time
this would be pretty different than the
clothes that are dyed harshly with
chemicals that were used to but dine
clothes naturally this way it would
allow for us to make sure that they're
more unique and environmentally
friendlier let's think about it fashion
today is all about individuality fashion
today is about managing your own
personal appearance to be just unique
enough to be cool these days everybody
has the ability to showcase their brand
their personal style across the world
through social media the pocket sized
billboards that we flicked through on
our Instagram feeds are chock-full of
models and taste makers that are
showcasing their individuality through
their personal micro brands but what
could be more personalized more unique
than clothes that change color over time
clothes that with each wash and with
each wear become more and more
one-of-a-kind people have been buying
and wearing ripped jeans for years so
this would just be another example of
clothes that exists in our wardrobe that
evolve with us over our lives their
shirt for example is one that much to
the dismay of my mother and the state of
her kitchen I died at home using tumeric
before coming here today
this shirt is something that no one else
none of my friends are gonna have on
their Instagram feed so it's unique but
more importantly it's naturally dyed now
I'm not suggesting that everybody dyed
their clothes in their kitchen sink at
home but if we were able to apply this
or more similar process on a commercial
scale then our need to rely on these
harsh chemical dyes for our clothes
could be easily reduced the two point
four trillion dollar fashion industry is
fiercely competitive so the business
that can provide a product at scale
while also promising its customers that
each and every garment will become more
and more unique over time will have a
serious competitive advantage brands
have been playing with customization for
years the rise of e-commerce services
like Indo Chino a bespoke suiting
platform and Tinker Tailor a bespoke
dress making platform have
customization possible from your couch
Nike and Adidas have been mastering
their online shoe customisation
platforms for years providing
individuality at scale is a challenge
that most consumer facing businesses
encounter so being able to tackle this
while also providing an environmentally
friendly product could lead to a pretty
seismic industry shift and at that point
it's not just about doing what's best
for our environment but also what's best
for the bottom line there's no fix all
and there's no one-step solution but we
can get started by designing clothes
with their death in mind the fashion
industry is the perfect industry to
experiment with and embrace change that
could one day get us to the sustainable
future we so desperately need thank you
[Applause]